844 204 rich number to dial we've got
him on from Bleacher Report because he
had an incredible piece about the human
element and fall out of the Astros
cheating scandals the author of ambush
by the Astros which you can read on
bleacher report.com right now Scott
Miller how are you Scott how are you I'm
doing fine well I guess what gave you
the idea to start going to people who
whose careers were altered by this what
we threw that well yeah I mean obviously
the big enormous story over the over the
winter and over the last couple of
months of baseball has been this Astro
scandal you know people can't seem to
get enough of it but you know we talk
too much about like what they did and
and you know the World Series in 2017
and Yu Darvish was he tipping his
pitches oh no now maybe the Astros knew
was coming and Darvish and Kershaw but
you know beyond that you know talking
talking with a couple my editors at
bleacher report you know we're kind of
almost brainstorming different you know
well there's a lot more to this than
just that and yeah it's a woman's just
you know that human cost in the turnout
there were a number of guys trying to
cling to their careers because I think
in professional sports in general but in
baseball rich tweet that's the one thing
the biggest thing I think the fans out
the average fan doesn't realize they say
oh these guys are major leaguers they
have it made the one thing I think that
people don't understand is the rampant
insecurity in the game from at all
levels you know even the superstars you
know they're you know there's they're
insecure because they have to stay
playing at that same level well you go
all the way down to the fringe guys
people trying to take their jobs and
then you know maybe the guy you know
they have a tenuous hold on their spots
anyway and then you get to a case like
the Astros in 2017 where you know they
knew what was coming
which pitches were going to be thrown
and you know the
fringe guys so many of them you know
after the guy faced the Astros and get
dispatched to the minor leagues later
that night or the next day and you know
we just wonder what what was that like
and especially now when these guys are
still some of them are out of the game
or some of them are clinging to their
careers and now that they know that what
they didn't know then you know what's
their reaction now and you know there's
just a human cause I know we get wrapped
up in numbers so much in sports in
general right but um you know the human
cost is always interesting to me so for
those who have not had the benefit of
reading your piece well give everyone an
example of a story of somebody who got
lit up and then lost their job on how
they're feeling about it today
Scott we-well just the guy I led with
Anthony Bass the excess Rangers 2017 and
he's he's in the minor leagues he's in
triple-a for the Texas Rangers and he's
trying to get back to the majors he had
been 20 13 14 15 16
he had started in the majors and and not
ever finished a full season but he had
pitched a fair amount
so then 2017 he's in the minors for
Texas still trying to get back to the
promised land so he was with their
triple-a team outside of Houston Round
Rock and he gets a call in May it's
early May and he gets he's pitched in a
game that they're triple-a game that
night he's back to his hotel or back to
his apartment where his pregnant wife is
and he arrives late after the game 11:30
or whatever at night and he gets called
from the Rangers hey we're in Houston
and we're calling you up we need you at
tomorrow's game we need you to drive
there's like maybe a three three and a
half hour drive and so he's like okay so
got to be there in time for tomorrow so
he drives through the night gets there
to Houston
and gets called on to pitch that day
couple innings gets hit pretty hard you
know according to the website that keeps
track of all the trash can bangs it was
minimal that day but there are some
bangs when he pitched so right after the
game it's called in the Jeff banisters
office then the manager of the Rangers
and he says hey I'm sorry do this to you
but you know we're gonna send you back
to triple-a so he drives the three hours
back meanwhile when he got called up you
know it's 11:30 at night he's leaving
two in a hurry for Houston his wife says
I thought it was very poignant says okay
I'll see you when I see you and in that
sentence to me and capsule eights the
the pride in your spouse the hope for
good things to happen I'll see you when
I see it yes you didn't know he might
have been in a major she might not seem
for a month for you know tell the next
time they visited her how one night
later he calls her hey I'm on the way
back home honey and he tells me she at
the time he said yeah I get it we
understand he had called off for one
game then sent back it happens sometimes
so he said actually she was more upset
that I was in the moment
she was like cheese basically like
they're abusing you you know they make
you drive three hours for one game and
make you send you back and little do
they know at the time it was the Astros
that were doing the abusing it's it's
amazing Scott I mean it's just it's just
remarkable and one of the stories that
you told or had told to you involving
Alex Cobb the the fact that he was told
after a gallon by one of the Astros that
he was tipping his pitches and instead
there were 20 bangs of the crash trash
can when Cobb was on the mound and he's
put it all together thinking that not
only was he cheated against but he was
having the tracks covered by a player
coming across as being altruistic to
help him out what in the world is the
psychology behind all that Scott yeah I
mean it turned out the the interesting
thing that happened
him and Chris Archer who at the time
were in the same rotation and Tampa Bay
and it was in the same series July 31st
August 2nd up to 2017 and you know you
can only conclude as Alex Cobb did that
basically you know somebody comes up to
him says hey hang with a man your stuff
was really good but you were tipping
your pitches I just want to tell you
well the only conclusion is basically
the Astros were trying to throw pitchers
in other clubs off the scent while of
what they were doing by saying hey you
know your stuffs good hang in there you
were just tipping your pitches and
you're out Cobb said he was a free agent
that winter he was about going to into
his free agent year he was having a
terrific season and that one outing in
Houston was by far his worst outing in
2017 and so he said looking back he felt
like his pitches were pretty good but it
was just getting clobbered and then now
knowing that what he knows now looking
back yeah he's like clearly they were
trying to throw me off the scent and the
problem aside from the face value part
of that he said the psychology of a
pitcher man when you get hit you know he
said I admit it we're like drama queens
and when we get hit hard it feels
sometimes like you're never going to
have another good outing and he said
they told me they wouldn't the guy
wouldn't tell me what I was tipping but
it was something with my glove he said
so right after that as you would imagine
Cobb his pitching coach and other
members of the race went to the computer
and they're watching over and over
looking for what am i doing what is he
doing with his glove
what's he tipping and it's cotton now
and he looks back it was all just a
bunch of wasted time and you know they
plant it the fall out of it was the next
several outings he was paranoid about
what he was throwing and making sure he
wasn't tipping when it turned out it
probably never was in the first place
last one for you Scott is F
determined or and what you're talking
any of these players the extent of
postseason use of this are we ever gonna
find out what actually happened the
Commissioner has said that based on
their evidence this scheme was used in
the 2017 postseason and we still don't
know which round it was in you know
unless it's on this website that you
mentioned your piece called sign
stealing scandal which is a game by game
breakdown that an Astros fans put
together do we know have you gleaned any
information on that front is exactly
what was used in the postseason by the
Astros it's it's still murky rich I
think it's pretty clear based on what
the commissioner said what the
investigation revealed and anecdotal
results I think it's pretty clear they
were doing this all the way through the
World Series I mean you know every round
of the postseason I mean the one I mean
Clayton Kershaw through 15 Game five of
the World Series in in Houston and that
was the game he got lit up pretty good
it was time for duty reported he threw
51 breaking balls and he got 0 swings
and misses I mean that is just almost
impossible to do especially for a
picture of Kershaw's caliber to throw
that many breaking balls and you get 0
swings and misses
so it's murky it's pretty much based on
the commissioners report that they were
it was going on throughout the
postseason he's probably also worth
mentioning that it's believed other
clubs were doing it too just not maybe
to the extent of the Astros maybe they
didn't haven't wired as well as they did
but you know that's the other thing here
too I think the Astros are getting all
the heat and you know I don't know that
other clubs were Lilly clean either but
you know what happened is you know
there's a whistleblower in the case of
the Astros Mike fiers basically handed
baseball its investigation
you know said here's what happened
here's how it happened and to your point
as well
I mean the whole video where people went
crazy over saying oh my gosh it looks
like Jose Altuve was wearing a buzzer
and there were reports that they were
wearing is they say wearable technology
fires didn't mention anything of that of
that nature and of course
Manfred said while we investigated that
but we couldn't we didn't find anything
but Manfred said can I say with a
hundred percent certainty they were not
wearing wearable technology no but we
couldn't find anything so that to me is
also just another example of you know
baseball hasn't found a whole lot or at
least hit they have they haven't
broadcasted other than you know what
Mike fiers laid out Scott thanks for the
time man great piece great job thank you
rich I appreciate you got it Scott
Miller check it out ambushed by the
Astros